vous propose de finir l'année 2016 en
beauté avec un épisode hardcore
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va essayer de voir
c'est comment on peut construire les
nombres dans la théorie la daf c'est en
utilisant uniquement les axiomes doigté
risée de ses c'est un exercice très
difficile très amusant et qui est
vraiment sur les fondations des
mathématiques
c'est aussi un exercice qui est très peu
présent notamment dans les livres de
cours assez difficile de trouver des
références qu'ils font toute la
présentation complète notamment
donc avant de commencer il faut que je
vous parle un petit peu de la théoriser
d'accès qui est la théorie des
mathématiques standard notamment parce
qu'elle a été utilisée par de nombreux
mathématiciens dont le célèbre nicolas
bourbaki donc j'ai par exemple cet
épisode l'a théorisé d'accès est une
théorie des ensembles ça veut dire que
tous les objets de la théorie sont des
ensembles les nombres les courbes les
fonctions tout ça en fait sont des
ensembles qu'on a construit qui se
comportent comme des nombres des courbes
et des fonctions et c'est pour ça qu'on
les appelle des nombres des cours et des
fonctions mais en fait tout dans la
théorie n'est que ensemble bon ça fait
trente secondes je vous ai déjà menti en
fait la théorie des ensembles de zeddam
scène n'est pas une théorie des
ensembles et je dirais même qu'il est
utile de garder en tête que les objets
de cette théorie ne sont en fait pas d
ensemble ce sont juste des objets de la
théorie à l'instar des objets de la
théorie de l'arithmétique de p and o qui
ne sont pas vraiment des nombres ce sont
juste des objets et ils ont juste de
telle ressemblance avec les nombres dans
le cas de l'arithmétique de pernod qu'on
a tendance à les appeler des nombres de
la même façon d'en adapter les objets de
la théoriser fc se comporte souvent
comme des ensembles de sorte que il est
assez pas trop grave me dire de les
appeler des ensembles en pratique
cependant il est utile de garder en tête
que ce ne sont en fait pas à des
ensembles tout ce qu'il y a dans la
théoriser d'accession des objets qui
sont reliés les uns avec les autres à
travers deux opérations le symbole
égalité et le symbole appartient à
mais encore une fois quand je dis le mot
égalité ou mot appartient à un jeu sur
interprète la théorie avec des mots qui
ne sont pas dans la théorie
ce qui importe c'est que le seigneur
égaler le symbole appartient à soi en
fait deux symboles qui
les différents ensembles les différentes
au gré plutôt de la théorie nfc et on
pourrait remplacer ces symboles par
d'autres symboles qui a priori n'ont
rien à voir avec notre intuition en tout
cas avec ce qu'on entend intuitivement
par appartient à et parts égales donc on
pourrait par exemple passer le symbole
appartient à part une flèche qui va de
la gauche perdra tout à droite vers la
gauche ça n'a pas d'importance
ce qui compte c'est que c'est vraiment
juste un symbole qui lie deux objets de
la théorie ceci étant dit ça va être
utile pour raisonner pour avoir une
intuition de ce qui se passe de souvent
interprété séance ces objets de la
théoriser décès comme étant des
ensembles ok donc la première étape pour
construire les nombres d'en adapter
c'est d'abord de construire un premier
objet dans un dlc et il ya un premier
objet qu'on va pouvoir construire à
l'aide d'un accès aux hommes de la
théorie qui est l'axiome de l'ensemble
vide donc l'axiom de l'ensemble vide
c'est un axiome qui s'écrit dans le
langage de la théoriser d'accès comme
ceci avec des symboles il existait des
pour tous donc si vous connaissez pas
ces symboles vous invite à aller voir
l'épisode 13 où j'ai parlé un peu de ses
symboles dans le cas de l'arithmétique
de p and o et donc si je traduis cette
formule logique de autorisé des fc en
français approximer quoi ça veut dire il
existe un objet x de la théorie tels que
pour tout objet y ait de la théorie il
est faux de dire que y appartient à x
donc c'est intuitivement ça veut dire
qu'il existe un objet x qui ne contient
aucun élément dans ça c'est bien sûr
notre ensemble vide et en particulier
comme mena une phrase qui commence par
un il existe ça veut dire qu'il existe
sept objets qu'on va pouvoir du coup le
nommer donc à chaque fois qu'il ya un
symbole il est gay c'est à dire qu'on va
pouvoir nommer cet objet on va l'appeler
1 semble vide
notez comme ça et du coup cette notation
va maintenant faire partie de notre
théorie est ce que vous propose de faire
maintenant c'est de prouver notre
premier théorème de la théorie à 9 c qui
dit que l'ensemble vie
et unique il n'y en a qu'un seul et pour
ça on va utiliser un autre actionne qui
est l'axiom d'extension nalité l'axiome
d'extension nalité dont qui s'écrit
formellement comme cela et intuitivement
ce qu'il dit c'est que si deux ensembles
contiennent les mêmes objets alors ils
sont égaux donc ça peut paraître évident
et c'est là qu'il est important de ne
pas perdre de vue le fait que l'on ne
traite pas vraiment d'ensemble on a
vraiment justes et des objets de la
théorie qui sont liées à travers le
symbole égale le symbole appartient et
cet axiome d'extension analyse et il est
très importante parce qu'il va nous
permettre de faire un lien entre les
deux liens qui existent entre les
différents objets de la théorie en
particulier cet axiome d'externalités
nous permet de dresser un lien entre
l'appartenance entre les ensembles et le
symbole égalité et en particulier on
peut l'appliquer à l'ensemble vide
disant que si deux objets de la théorie
sont telles que tous les deux ne
contiennent aucun objet donc tous les
deux vérifie en fait l'axiome de l'ordre
semblent vides alors ils sont forcément
ego et ça ça montre que le seul objet de
la théoriser d'accès qui se comporte
comme l'ensemble vide et en fait égal à
l'ensemble vie autrement dit l'ensemble
vide et unique
super on a un autre premier théorème ok
maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est
construire d'autres ensembles à partir
de l'ensemble vide en particulier pour
ce faire on peut utiliser l'axiome de la
paire l'axiome de la paire il dit que si
j'ai deux ensembles x et y
alors je peux construire un ensemble
c'est qui va contenir en gros les objets
x et y
donc cet ensemble qui contient deux
autres objets on le note souvent juste
entre accolade x y et l'existence de cet
ensemble qui contient x et y
nous est donnée par le symbole il existe
de l'axiome de la perte
maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est
appliquer l'axiome de la paire à
l'ensemble vide et l'ensemble vide
donc on remplace x et y parle ensemble
vide
et ça ça nous dit qu'il existe un
ensemble qui contient l'ensemble vide et
l'ensemble vide mais du coup on se rend
compte que cet ensemble là il ne
contient que l'ensemble vide c'est à
dire que le seul objet qui
par tient à l'ensemble qu'on a construit
avec l'axiome de la paire et l'ensemble
vide
du coup cet ensemble on peut le réécrire
comme étant égal à l'ensemble qui ne
contient que l'ensemble vide
il faut faire bien attention à
l'ensemble vide n'est pas la même chose
que l'ensemble qui contient juste
l'ensemble vide particulier semble vide
n'a aucun élément alors que l'ensemble
qui contient l'ensemble vide à un
élément qui est l'ensemble vide
plus généralement avec l'axiome de la
paire en posant x est égal à y
je vais pouvoir construire un ensemble
qui ne contient que l'élément x
lorsqu'on appelle parfois un singleton
le singleton qui ne contient que
l'ensemble x ok donc avec l'axiome de la
paire étant donné n'importe quel
ensemble on est capable de construire un
singleton qui ne contient que cet
ensemble là maintenant on va utiliser
aussi l'axiome de l'union qui dit quand
vous on peut prendre l'union de deux ans
semble donc si on a deux ensembles x et
y
alors on peut construire un ensemble une
qui va contenir tous les éléments de x
et tous les éléments de y
il va même de contenir que les éléments
qui sont dans x ou de y
en fait l'action de l'union est un peu
plus compliqué que ça il dit que si j'ai
un ensemble x alors je peux prendre
l'union des éléments de x mais je vous
laisse vous convaincre qu'en combinant
l'action de l'union et laxime de la
paire je peux bien faire ce que j'ai dit
que je ferai donc là encore il ya un
symbole il existe dans cet axiome qui va
nous permettre de définir à partir de
deux ensembles xy l'ensemble union qui
va on va noter du coup x union y ok
maintenant on va pouvoir construire une
suite d'objets qui vont être assez
structuré donc le premier objet ça va
être l'ensemble vide
ensuite on va faire l'ensemble vide
union le singleton ensemble vide
1 toutes les opérations on les a bien
défini avec la xoom de la paire et
l'accès aux hommes de l'union
ce deuxième ensemble que l'on a
construit on va l'appeler un donc c'est
juste un nom qu'on donne à cet ensemble
l'a ensuite à partir de l'ensemble et on
va construire l'ensemble 2 qui va être
égal à 1 union l'ensemble qui ne
contient que 1 le singleton qui ne
contient que 1
et comme vous l'imaginez à partir de
n'importe quel énième éléments
construits dans cette construction cette
suite de construction on peut construire
l'élément qui vient après
qui va être
une union le singleton qui contient aide
et pour simplifier les notations ce que
je vais faire c'est donner un nom à cet
ensemble l union l'ensemble qui vont
ajuster rennes on va l'appeler sn donc s
est ni les biens des phonies fini pour
n'importe quel objet n de la théorie des
fc garder ça en tête et donc
intuitivement ce qui va se passer c'est
que le premier élément dans ça me vide
la correspondre à zéro suite le deuxième
à 1 celui qui vient après à 2 puis
ensuite trois et ainsi de suite
et ainsi on pourrait avoir construit
tous les objets qui correspondent à des
nombres entiers naturels
ça c'est vraiment excellent mais en fait
ça va pas suffire pour aller vraiment
plus loin et en fait à partir de là
c'est pas évident notamment de définir
de l'addition n'a même pas
l'arithmétique de pernod que l'on peut
déduire de ces constructions là pour
vraiment aller plus loin notamment
définir l'addition et la multiplication
ce qui va nous falloir faire s'est
regroupé tous ces objets dans un
ensemble on a envie de construire
l'ensemble de tous les entiers naturels
de tous les héros 1-2 donc de tous les
objets qu'on a construit avec cette
suite de construction 0 h 01 et 0 et
ainsi de suite
et c'est là que c'est bon de garde en
tête qu'on n'est pas vraiment dans une
théorie des ensembles ne peut pas
collecter tous les objets comme cela
parce que si on avait le droit de
qualité ces objets comme cela on pourra
collecter tous les objets de la théorie
construire l'ensemble de tous les
ensembles et aboutit à un paradoxe comme
ceux dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode 16
par exemple paradoxe de russell donc
gardons vraiment en tête qui ne s'agit
pas vraiment d'ensemble que l'on traite
dans cette théorie on ne peut pas
construire vraiment des ensembles tout
ce qu'on peut construire c'est ce qui
est autorisé par les axiomes de la
théorie est là en particulier on a un
axiome qui avait lettres l'axiome de
l'infini qui est l'action qui permet de
construire des
objet qui contiennent un certain sens
une infinité encore fait je suis
interprète la théorie mais en gros
l'actionnaire a fini c'est l'action qui
va nous permettre de construire des
ensembles infini alors qu'est-ce qu'il
dit cet axiome de l'infini cette action
de l'infini il dit qu' il existe un
ensemble que j'ai appelé grandir pour un
fini tel que si un objet x2 fc
appartient à l'ensemble i alors le
successeur de x1 l'ensemble construit
comme étant x union le singleton x va
aussi appartenir à l'ensemble infinie y
ait une autre chose que cet ensemble qui
doit vérifier c'est que l'ensemble vide
doit appartenir à y ait là on a envie de
dire que du coup il va être égal à
l'ensemble les anti naturel
eh bien c'est faux je sais pas si vous
voyez pourquoi c'est faux de dire que y
est égale forcément à l'ensemble des
anti naturel a priori en fait d'après
ces définitions y pourrait être en fait
beaucoup plus grands ils proviennent
notamment contenir des branches
parallèle et même pas mal d'objets qui
ont rien à voir a priori avec les
ensembles entiers naturels notamment y
pourra être un ensemble qui contient des
ordinaux comme ceux dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 8
l'astuce pour construire un ensemble n
va être d'utiliser le schéma d'actium de
compréhension qui est un axiome un petit
peu compliqué dans le sens déjà où il ya
en fait une infinité de telles actions
un peu comme il y avait une infinité de
huitième axiome de l'arithmétique de
paix à notre m'a parlé dans l'épisode 13
de schémas d'actium de compréhension il
dit que si j'ai un ensemble x qui va
être un grand ensemble je peux
construire 1 go un sous-ensemble de x
quand je vais appeler y ici tel que les
éléments petit x2 y sont telles que
petit hic c'est à partir d'un grand x
donc ça c'est à dire que y est un sous
ensemble de grands x est tel que une
certaine formule pay de x2 petit x est
vrai est donc la formule pay de petit x
est une formule qui doit pouvoir être
écrite dans le langage 2 à 9 c est en
fait à chaque fois que je peux écrire
une formule dans le langage de nfc
je peux utiliser l'axiome de schémas de
compréhension pour cette formule là donc
j'insiste un tout petit peu sur le fait
que la formule en question doit pouvoir
s'écrire dans le langage des élèves
c'est ça ça correspond à dire que ces
décès doit être une logique du premier
ordre et être une logique du premier
ordre c'est important parce que le
théorème de complétude de gödel celui
qui permet de dire que à partir du
moment où une théorie est consistante
alors il existe des modèles de la
théorie ne pas entrer dans les détails
de ce que ça veut dire mais en gros
c'est un tome qui est très rassurant
et c'est pour ça que l'on préfère les
logiques du premier rang donc encore une
fois le schéma d'actium de compréhension
contient un symbole
il existe ça veut dire que veut pouvoir
définir un nouvel objet en fonction donc
de la formule paix et du premier
ensemble quand x alors du coup cet
ensemble y est que je construis ainsi
que je pourrais lui donner une notation
qui fait intervenir que grand x et la
formule paix mais de façon classique en
mathématiques parce que c'est plus clair
souvent de l'écrire ça comme ça on va
plutôt privilégié comme notation des
grecs y est égal à l'ensemble des
petites x appartenant à un grand x tel
que p 2 x 115 x à chaque fois que j'ai
un objet grand x2 adf c est que j'ai une
formule pay que je peux écrire dans le
langage 2 et des fc alors je peux
construire cet ensemble qui est y qui
est l'ensemble des petits six
appartements ticks quelques pdx ok donc
si je récapitule un petit peu ce qu'on a
vu dernièrement on a vu qu'il existait
un ensemble infinie i qui contient
l'ensemble vide et qui contient tous les
successeurs de ces éléments et on a vu
qu'on pouvait exister à ce schéma de
compréhension qui permettait de
construire des sous ensembles tels que
une certaine propriété est vérifiée et
donc intuitivement ce que je vais
essayer de faire maintenant c'est de
construire un ensemble d anti naturel
comme étant le sous-ensemble de grands
ti qui est un certain sens le plus petit
qui satisfasse
la définition de garantie c'est à dire
le fait qu'ils contiennent ensemble vide
et tout successeur de ces éléments
du coup je vais définir l'ensemble haine
qui est égal à l'ensemble des éléments
petit n appartenant à yves tels que si
je prends n'importe quel ensemble qui
satisfait la définition de e-books
rappelle inductif c'est à dire je prends
n'importe quel ensemble grands titres
tels que l'ensemble vide à partir un
grand x et si un élément petit x
appartient un grand x alors le
successeur de x appartient quand x si je
prends n'importe quel ensemble grand x
qui satisfait donc ça forcément petit n
va appartenir à grand x et en gros cette
définition là qui est assez astucieuse
elle revient à dire que l'ensemble haine
des anti naturel va être le plus petit
ensemble inductif donc qui satisfait ça
alors ce qui est intéressant à voir
c'est que cette formule est là servant à
l'envi qu'elle garantit pas vraiment que
l'ensemble elle ne contient que
l'ensemble vide et les successeurs de
l'ensemble vide
on a un petit peu le même problème que
celui dont on avait déjà parlé dans pour
l'arithmétique de piano c'est difficile
d'exclure notamment les branches
parallèle lorsqu'on construit cet
ensemble n ici ceci étant dit on à un
théorème important on peut prouver par
rapport à cet ensemble haine qui est le
principe de récurrence donc le principe
de récurrence qu'est ce qu'il me dit
nous dit que si je construis un ensemble
grand x qui est l'ensemble des éléments
end aux grands thèmes qu'ils vérifient
une certaines propriétés paix de haine
alors pour montrer que l'aveu propriété
p2 n est égal est vrai pour tout élément
n 2 grands thèmes faudrait montrer que
grant x et du coup est égal à l'ensemble
end et antinaturel et pour ce faire il
suffit de montrer que l'ensemble vide
appartient à un grand x et que si un
élément n à partir un grand x alors s n
va appartenir à grand x lui aussi est
donc on a ses théorèmes qui me dit que
si x est telle que ces deux propriétés
sont vraies alors x est égal à grand
peine ou autrement dit la propriété p2 n
est vrai pour tout n appartenant à grand
peine et ce qui est amusant c'est que ce
théorème qui est absolument remarquable
est fondamental dans tout les
mathématiques aims c'est le principe de
la preuve par récurrence qui qui sont
sans laquelle on pourra quasiment rien
faire en mathématiques
elle est juste conséquente de la
définition astucieuse que l'on a eue de
l'ensemble end et antinaturel ok donc ça
y est on a notre ensemble des anti
naturel mais on n'a pas encore défini
l'addition ni la multiplication entre
les anti naturel encore une fois sans la
dissidence en multiplication on peut
rien faire comme j'en ai parlé dans
l'épisode de 10,9 pour définir
l'addition et la multiplication en fait
ce qu'on va faire c'est définir des
sous-ensembles de triplets x y et z de
normandie naturels tels que ans
activement on va voir xp cidre et qui
est égal à z si et seulement si x y z
appartiennent à l'ensemble addition sauf
que bien sûr là on a une définition un
peu circulaire parce que je définis
l'addition par rapport à l'ensemble
adt et je définis rapport à l'édition en
fait ce qu'on va faire c'est définir
l'ensemble had indépendamment de
l'addition est ensemble à 2 comment on
va le définir on va le définir comme un
sous-ensemble déjà de l'ensemble des
triplets d'une omlt anti naturel alors
il faudrait que je vous explique comment
construire du coût des triplets de
nombres entiers naturels ou plus
généralement si jr un ensemble x
ensemble y comment je peux construire
une l'ensemble des pères xy donc
l'ensemble des pères xy c'est ce qu'on
appelle le produit cartésien entre grant
x et quand tu y es là une façon un peu
astucieuse jeu sur lequel j'ai pas envie
d'insister donc vous donne juste la
formule ici pour définir le produit
cartésien et donc cette forme est là
repose notamment sur un axiome qu'on a
vu dans l'épisode 16 qui est l'axiome de
l'ensemble des partis qui dit que si je
prends un ensemble grand tic savoir je
peux construire un autre ensemble qui
contient activement les sous-ensembles
de x men bref passons sur les détails
supposons que l'on sache construire du
coup elle croit n 3 n donc l'ensemble
produit cartésien
2 n 3 fois on note aussi n au cube et
qui du coup l'ensemble des triplets
d'anti naturel ce que l'on a envie de
faire c'est maintenant construire un
sous-ensemble de haine au cube et qui a
les bonnes propriétés qui va en gros
satisfaire les axiomes de l'arithmétique
de pernod pour l'addition bien pour
savoir ce qu'on va faire c'est on va
d'abord construire une formule logique
un sous-ensemble de neo cube a les
bonnes propriétés de l'addition si déjà
il contient tous les triplets de la
forme n ensemble vide
n donc ça c'est ainsi seulement ça
correspond à dire qu'un fuseau est égale
à la haine pour tout n appartenant
raconte n est-ce qu'on va vouloir dire
c'est que si un triplet nmp appartient à
l'ensemble
x alors n smsp est aussi un élément de
l'ensemble grand x dont classer ces deux
conditions corresponde vraiment aux
axiomes de l'addition de l'arithmétique
de paix à nos mets donc a priori aussi x
satisfait ces deux conditions donc si la
formule pay 2x ici qu'on a défini est
vrai alors x satisfait les bons critères
mais il risque d'être trop gros on
pourra par exemple prendre x est égal à
hainaut cube n occupe l'ensemble de tous
les triplets satisfait ces conditions
mais ce n'est pas le bon ensemble
addition que l'on aimerait considéré et
là on va utiliser la même astuce que
précédemment
on va considérer en gros le plus petit
sous-ensembles grand x et de haine au
cube qui satisfait ses conditions en
particulier on va définir had add qui
est égal à l'ensemble des tripes et x y
z de haine ou tubes tels que pour tout
objet x qui est un sous-ensemble dano
cube 6 x passe le critère que l'on a
donné précédemment donc si p2i de c'est
vrai alors forcément xxi durée exacte
appartiennent à x et envoie avec ses
définitions construit le plus petit
ensemble had qui satisfait ses
propriétés et ça ça va correspondre
intuitivement à l'addition alors de là à
se convaincre que l'ensemble at
correspond parfaitement à l'addition des
antilles natural il ya tout un pas et
font quand même pas mal de travail pour
s'en convaincre
je vous propose quand même d'essayer de
voir pourquoi est ce que il ya toujours
moins résultat une addition donc envie
de dire que si je prends n'importe quel
x n'importe quel y
alors il existe un z tels que x y z va
appartenir à l'ensemble adresse première
qu'il expulse y va être égale un certain
nombreuses aides et bien pour pouvoir
prouver cela on peut y aller par
récurrence qu'on peut utiliser le
théorème de récurrence qu'on l'a vu
précédemment en commençant par le cas où
y est égal à zéro
dans le cas où il y est égal à zéro et
ben peut prendre z est égal à x et on
voit que le triptyque c 0x appartient à
tous les objets grant x qui satisfont la
commission p 2 x et en particulier du
coup ça va pas retenir l'ensemble haddad
aidé et qui plus est si on sait que x y
z appartient déjà à dd on sait que x s y
z appartient à dd et du coup pour x et s
y on sait qu'il existe un élément que
l'on peut construire ou qui est s z tels
que x s y y et z appartient à ad dsac
bien l'hérédité de la recursion du coût
en utilisant le terme de récurrence on
sait que pour tous x y
il existe un z tels que ici leur exode
appartient à ad d vous voyez que rien
que se convaincre que l'addition est
toujours au moins un résultat c'est pas
facile mais bref
du coup de la même façon on peut définir
la multiplication en utilisant notamment
l'addition que l'on avait déjà défini et
du groupe traduisant une certaine
manière les axiomes de l'arithmétique de
p and o est encore une fois en utilisant
l'astuce convient de voir pour prendre
le plus petit des ensembles qui
satisfont les axiomes de wright
multiples et de pernod et du coup avec
un peu de travail ont réussi ainsi à
définir à la fois leur semble et
antinaturel les additions et la
multiplication et du coup on a en
particulier démontré que l'arithmétique
de piano et d'une certaine manière
incluse dans un fc est donc en
particulier que le théorème de gödel va
s'appliquer azf c'est ok on a construit
l'ensemble des anti naturel on a fait le
plus dur en fait une fois comme ça en me
disant c'est naturel avec l'addition et
la multiplication
bon il reste encore une énorme astuces
qui avait être las tus des espaces
caution qui est un truc très beau
baptiste ont mis en particulier va
définir les autres ensembles comme z os
qu on sentait sentir la vie sont des
rationnelle et puis même l'ensemble des
réelles elles entendent les nombreux
complexes à coup de dés ce pass caution
donc pour faire un espace quotient
d'abord il faut définir une relation
d'équivalence donc on va commencer par
considérer l'ensemble m² des pères
dentier naturel et ensuite on va définir
une relation dès qu il en soit on va
dire que ab va être équivalent à céder
si on a envie de dire qu'en gros si à
moins bva est égal à ces - des deux
sortes me définir les antilles est
relatif comme étant des différences
entre des entiers naturels sauf qu'on
n'a pas défini la soustraction et cm
galère de définir la soustraction de
nombres entiers naturels puisque dès que
b va être plus grand que ah bah on n'a
pas de résultats et l'astuce de bourbaki
ça va être de voir qui est une façon
équivalente de dire qu'à moins bête et
gallas et moins dé qui n'utilisent pas
la soustraction mal pour ça on rajoute
des deux côtés on rajoute b des deux
côtés et du coup on obtient l'égalité
qu'il faudrait démontrer qui nous dit
que à puce dette égale à b + c est ça
c'est on va définir sa commune aux
relations équivalence on va dire que à
une relation air qui lie à b et c d et
qui va être voix si et seulement si à
plus d est égal à b plus c'est donc là
j'utilise le symbole plus ces symboles
égal pour ce soit plus clair plus facile
à comprendre mais techniquement ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est traduire tout ça
dans le langage de la théorie edf c'est
donc ça correspondrait à cette formule
là qui dirait qu'ils existent et rajoute
à z en fait qui est égal aux deux tels
que à la fois à des aides et
bcz appartiennent à l'ensemble add
ensuite qui va être important de montrer
c'est que cette relation air est une
relation qu'on appelle l'équivalence
pour ça il ya trois propriétés que cette
relation air doit satisfaire donc ces
trois propriétés sont la réflexivité la
symétrie et à transitivité donc laraque
si la réflexivité elle dit qu'on doit
avoir tout une relation entre à b et ab
donc là il suffit de prendre z qui est
le résultat de l'addition du coup on
aurait à la fois à bz à partir un add on
à bedzed à partir d'un add donc ça ça
prouve la réflexivité le fait qu'ils
aient toujours une relation entre à b et
ab
ensuite la deuxième propriété c'est la
symétrie c'est à dire que si on a nos
relations entre à b et c des alors une
relation entre cd et ab donc là encore
une fois il suffit d'écrire le truc et
on voit que c'est clermont fra 6 1
pouces d est égal à bp s'est alors bpc
est égale à la publicité et enfin la
troisième propriété est la transitivité
qui me dit que si on a une relation
entre à b et c d et si on a un ratio
entre c d et e f
alors on a une relation entre ab et ef
donc là cette fois c'est un poil plus
triki pas trop insister dessus mais je
vous invite à vous convaincre que c'est
qu'armand brad est donc maintenant on a
une relation de d'équivalence et ça ça
veut dire que on peut partitionner on
peut découper neutre ensemble m² en
région qui sont équivalentes
graphiquement ça correspond à ce dessein
là c'est à dire que ces espèces deux
tranches à chaque fois diagonale qui
sont équivalentes tout en les unes avec
les autres l'intérieur d'une tranche
chacune de ces tranches et c'est aussi
ce qu'on appelle une classe
d'équivalence c'est-à-dire qu'elle
contient l'ensemble des objets qui sont
équivalents entre eux et bien l'ensemble
l'aide des antilles relative que l'on va
construire ça va être l'ensemble de ces
classes des clients c'est-à-dire
l'ensemble de ces tranches
donc c'est un ensemble d'ensemble de
paires de claques vous pouvez remarquer
que j'utilise un langage créé ensemble
east pour donner l'intuition de ce qu'il
se passe encore une fois pour vraiment
bien construire la chose il faut il
parler uniquement en terme
ces deux d'actium deux élèves c est bien
la façon dont technique de construire
l'espace caution c'est d'utiliser
l'axiome d'une part de l'ensemble des
parties puis le schéma d'actium de
compréhension pour prendre juste
seulement les sous-ensembles qui
contiennent tous les éléments d'une
classe d'équivalence cela correspond à
cette formule qui est écrite justicier
donc de la même façon on peut définir
l'ensemble cud et rationnels comme un
ensemble quotient donc là l'ensemble des
départs qu'on va considérer ces
ensembles z croit n - 0 donc l'ensemble
des entiers n'ont nulle je vous invite
aussi à vous demander comment on peut
construire l'ensemble m - 0 petit indice
faut utiliser à l'action de shima de
compréhension on va dire que ab est
équivalent à céder 6 à foix des est égal
à des fois c'est donc là c'est
exactement la même construction que tout
à l'heure on montre que cette relation
là est une relation d'équivalence puis
on construit l'ensemble cocciante qui
correspond à cet ensemble équivalent et
bien c'est cet espace caution quand on
va appeler cul qui est donc un ensemble
de sous ensembles de père dentier et le
premier de ses ventes et 40 y relatifs
est lui-même un ensemble de sous
ensembles de perdre antinaturel vous
commencez à voir à sentir que ça c'est
abstrait c'est assez compliqué mais au
final on peut traiter ces objets comme
les objets on a l'habitude de traiter et
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle tous à des
noms dans vertu mais encore une fois de
la citation de poing qui arrive ok donc
on a les nombres entiers naturels les
antilles est relatif on a même les
rationnels va maintenant passer à ceux
qui sont les plus cheap à mon sens ce
sont les nombres réels nombreux réel en
fait il ya deux définitions possibles il
ya les coupes de de dawkins et d'un côté
et de l'autre côté on a suite de
coaching donc techniquement il y aura
pas mal de travail de débroussaillage à
faire pour pouvoir définir tout ça donc
je vais être beaucoup moins rigoureux
pour introduire un nombre réel parce que
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
intuitivement les nombres réels de
docking pour commencer ce sont des
façons de couper l'ensemble des nombres
rationnelle en deux parties gauche et à
droite
donc ils ne sortent que tout élément à
gauche est strictement plus petit que
tout élément à droite et vice et versa
tout témoin grotte est strictement le
plus grand que tout élément à gauche et
je peux construire une relation
d'équivalent sur tous ses pairs de ab
donc là il faudrait que travailleur un
petit peu contre qu'il s'agit bien d'une
relation d'équivalence mais à partir de
cette c'est une relation d'équivalent ça
je peux concevoir un ensemble caution et
cet ensemble quotient là va être
ensemble des réelles après faudrait
définir l'addition mais la
multiplication sur les réelles mais à la
fin on arrive à avoir l'ensemble des
réelles avec l'addition et la
multiplication et même le symbole
inférieures ou égales
donc là on a vraiment le corps des
réelles avec sa relation d'ordre
là on est vraiment très très bien donc
ça c'est la construction de deux quines
il ya une relation équivalente qui est
l'arbre la construction de
cochet qui n'est pas dieu à coucher mais
c'est cochet que certaines des idées de
base de cette construction notamment les
suites de coaching pour avoir définir la
suite de coups chiffres d'abord que je
vous définissent ce que c'est une
fonction une fonction dans élèves c'est
donc une fonction par exemple 2e dans f
donc on note aussi m puissance alors
elle puissants se savait de quoi ça va
être un ensemble de sous ensembles de
eux croient fpt plus précisément c'est
l'ensemble des fonctions petit f
appartenant à l'ensemble des parties
deux croix f tels que pour tout élément
x 2 e
il existe un unique élément y de f tels
que xy à partir à f
alors c'est à dire quoi il existe un
unique j'ai une notation raccourci mais
en fait je peux la développer ça veut
dire que non seulement non seulement il
existe un y
appartenant à f tels que x y est un
élément de petit f
mais aussi si je prends deux éléments y
et z appartenant à f
et si je sais que xy appartient à petit
f et x z appartient à petit et f
alors forcément y est égal à z bref les
détaillants importent peu toujours est
il que si je prends deux objets de l'été
aux lycées je peux définir l'ensemble
des fonctions de du premier en solo
objets dans le deuxième objet et ça ça
va me permettre de définir l'ensemble
des suites à valeur rationnelle donc
l'ensemble des ensembles qu'une
puissance n
dans cet ensemble de suite rationnelle
je peux me concentrer uniquement sur
l'ensemble des suites qui sont dites de
kochi des suites de kochi elles ont
cette propriété l'a pas trop rentrer
dans les détails mais intuitivement ça
veut dire que ces suites de couches ils
ne peuvent plus trop varié au bout d'un
moment elles ont et se stabilise et donc
on envie de dire qu' elle se stabilise
vers une valeur qui est forcément une
valeur réelle
et là on peut définir nos relations
d'équivalent sur l'ensemble des suites
de kochi en disant que dessus de kochi
sont équivalentes
si lorsque je considère la suite qui est
la soustraction des deux que je vous
soumets en faisant abstraction des deux
alors cette suite qui asus traction des
deux se rapprochent allait finalement
près d'eux et
les façon de formaliser tout ça bref
j'ai encore une relation d'équivalent se
ressemblent du sud yoshi du coup je peux
considérer l'espace caution et bien je
peux définir cet espace caution comme
étant l'ensemble des nombres réels ce
qui est assez magique c'est que du coup
ensemble des réelles construite par la
construction de deux quines va être
équivalent doit être isomorphe 1 common
jeudi à l'ensemble des suites l'ensemble
des ombres aurait elle construite par
suite de cauchy enfin dernière chose
l'ensemble des nombres complexes je vais
m'arrêter sur les nombreux complexes
n'ont semblé nombre complexe lui peut
être très facilement détruits comme
ensemble comme étant l'ensemble air
croit m ce qui est un peu plus difficile
à définir c'est l'addition et la
multiplication sur l'ensemble des
nombres complexes mais ça c'est pas bien
compliqué mais la plus belle définition
que je connaisse mois des nombres
complexes est en fait plutôt de dire de
définir d'abord l'ensemble des polynômes
à valeur réelle doncker crochet x ont
peut définir ensuite des sous ensembles
de cet espace de pays nomme particulier
x car est plus un père crochet x6 avec
l'ensemble des polynômes qui sont
divisibles par x clara est puissant et
comme expert est plus un air crochet x
est un idéal maximale de aircrew chix
vous pas rentrer un héritage aujourd'hui
de ce que ça veut dire mais en tout cas
ça va nous permettre de définir un
espace quotient enfin qu'il va être du
coup un corps caution lorsqu'on prend un
fait un anneau et qu'on divise pas un
idéal maximale on obtient toujours un
corps et ce corps là ça est record des
nombres complexes vue m'arrêter là avec
cette jolie définition à mon sens mais
j'espère que je vous ai
donner une idée en tirer de comment est
ce que tous les objets des mathématiques
classiques peuvent être déduites des
actions aux fondamentaux et surtout
l'utilisation de ces espaces caution à
partir des axiomes de la théorie azf c
est comment du coup cet essai contient
tous ces objets mathématiques